okay first game for today this blazing
horses from the Netherlands I go from
Kings Indian again and you choose the
some a quiet set up with Bishop g5 you
know I go for banco light black approach
this is rather interesting because some
you could also take with the night but
then we should be 94 is quite quite an
interesting way to play let's see what
happens I choose either III I go Queen a
five in order to play 90 for a possible
maybe he's got 92 now but is he choose
to take what about 94 now could take his
seven but I know I can take C 3 it looks
interesting at least
I didn't think this was possible at all
can I just take a play rook e8 first and
then take on c3 let's show what what
what what's this idea 93 then 22 or
otherwise i'm just-just winning lots of
material I could also just take with the
bishop seems also winning okay but
Knight c3 first Queen d2 and then what
not sure I'm also pinned here ok let's
go for this one so you cannot play king
e 2 because of Bishop a six so I guess
92 but then I just take it I'll ended I
don't see what what is playing after
this yeah maybe can play rook see one
but i would have a double check here
kingi to
and then maybe Bishop a 6 King f3 it
looks looks very weird but okay after I
have to go for this ok Knight f3 it's
rather simple on King e2 i also have on
94 but just have a quick look if i have
something even better does it doesn't
look like it it's quite handy to have
the rukon yet so on 24 i can i can take
just with the Queen
yeah that's just the Queen
no move white resides yeah that was
quick I guess he just he just cannot
take on a six this is looking very
problematic already with a 94 to come
off it should be seven for certain no
losses outright but i'm not sure what
else he could could play actually i
think in this position you should go on
92 and prevent 94 and also on get the
idea from playing 94 immediately I'm not
sure it's looking a bit strange maybe
even for black yeah after this it was so
really really easy to play